[Music]
everybody was fine there's enough water
for the farms there's enough water for
the hops
the farmers they weren't using their own
wells because they were getting water
allocated to them through the canals to
the state
but since the drought all that water is
you know it's not available to them
anymore so now they're starting to use
their own wells and it seems like when
they do that now the houses around them
are starting to go dry
so i'm just filling her up so we're
gonna go ahead and connect to the pipe
there chris is a water hauler hired to
truck in portable water to hundreds in
the san joaquin valley
she works for self-help enterprises an
ngo that provides emergency water
services to residents whose wells are
failing them
in 2021 973 residential wells came up
dry throughout california
just 85 did the year before
most of these wells are in the heart of
the san joaquin valley one of the
world's most productive agricultural
regions
the water comes through that pipe goes
into our tank and then it comes back out
goes down into that
tank into the pump right here and they
pump it through our
old existing well into the places in the
house
we did run out completely
we had no water for a few days and it
was so hard
you either ran down the pilot and took a
shower went to someone's house
or you
just went and bought bottled water and
did sponge baths
the demand has been pretty high um
average we you know during peak drought
during summer we were getting over 25
calls a day with
domestic well owners calling in saying
their well has gone dry
madeira has been hit pretty hard and so
as to larry county but the entire
valley has been
pretty
dry
and so right now we're in the city of
madera
a real hot spot
during this year's drought you'll see
really all throughout the central valley
which is nut trees uh and there's not
treats for for tens uh maybe even
hundreds of miles stretching
all throughout the basin of the central
valley
california's central valley is kind of
the
americas like bread basket of food right
it can cause some problems between the
local population and the farmers right
agriculture consumes like 80 percent of
california's water and that's a lot of
water
[Music]
it's just getting worse instead of
better and i know the farmers need water
because without the farming
we're not going to have food
but
they go down so deep because they don't
have the irrigation like they used to
california's water supply comes from a
lot of different sources we get rain and
snow in the winter that provides runoff
to our rivers and to our reservoirs
but we're also very dependent on what's
called groundwater that is underground
aquifers that often are consist of water
that's been there for thousands of years
that has been laid down by nature over
time groundwater comes from rainfall
that falls on the ground and then slowly
seeps into these underground aquifers
and one of the big challenges with
california groundwater today is that
we're pumping it out much faster than
nature naturally replenishes it
as
groundwater levels drop
shallow groundwater wells dry up those
wells tend to be the wells that supply
our local communities or our local
towns in the central valley of
california
whereas agricultural interests are able
to drill much deeper wells and continue
to overdraft groundwater
and the consequences are really being
felt by front line
communities by poor farming communities
by disadvantaged
agricultural communities
that are seeing wells dry up faster
a lot of the communities that we see are
farm working communities
who wake up four or five in the morning
to go
attend to these farms a lot of these
communities are really dependent on
these farm owners to provide
the resources in terms of
paying jobs but unfortunately those
farmworkers take advantage of the fact
that
the majority of these workers are
undocumented immigrants
who are
really in the
ability to
take
better paying jobs and so they recognize
that
pay them
pretty much
starvation wages and
to top that off
when these communities come home
they don't have clean drinking water in
their homes
that's a real tragedy
so right now if a
household in the central valley
uh well wench ride they would have to
probably wait about eight months until
they're able to install a new well or to
deepen their existing well
and the cost of those uh wells are
ranging uh about forty thousand dollars
per each well and so for a lot of these
communities uh that's more
than they make in a year
yes
the
[Music]
love
[Music]
you